are you saying no but what i was saying
earlier is that what you're saying
earlier is
there's i think comics calling out other
comics and getting them canceled or
whatnot i think that we for some reason
we should be able to
we should we got to weed that out sure i
mean because that right there it's like
it's hard enough you know if it's sexual
based
that's one thing what can you do exactly
yeah you know what i mean oops you [ __ ]
like that it's like what do you want to
do yeah yeah that's a real crime yeah
that's
what i mean but if it's words just for
comedians and i'm not i don't mean to
blanket
comedians but i feel my train of thought
is and
you know is that is that uh if it's just
words especially in a joke you can't
you cross that line and want to cancel
and bring these things up and look what
so and so said it's like get out
get out of the you're not you're i know
you'll maybe get opportunity
fine yeah but get the [ __ ] out of the
business i i'm like automatically
it doesn't matter how funny or i'm like
you're out dude get out that's [ __ ]
that's such a little [ __ ] move
i went to a club once that like everyone
hired right everyone played it
and i didn't play it for many many years
and then one day
10 years later or whatever i finally get
a weekend there
right and i show up and i i play the
weekend
myself and then sunday night the manager
comes in to me and goes
oh man you're nothing like what i
thought you were gonna be like
and i'm like why i've never been here
before he's like some guy told me like a
while back how you were right that i did
this
i do that this and that and i'm like
i've never done those things
right so some piece of [ __ ] comic right
just rattles his mouth off
right and when you do that you know you
that could
lead to no work for somebody sure you
know i mean and it's like
ever since then it's like i just can't
tolerate that [ __ ]
that's and you know what too i think
there's a big thing too it's like the
you know the victim
mentality it's like hey listen something
happens in your career
i'm just talking about comedians like
because something happens because i feel
like i don't think qualified to you know
talk about i feel like sometimes
even i do it i go off on rants making
these statements i'm like dude you just
tell the jokes that the [ __ ] funny
bones stupid
you know like you don't know what you're
talking about you have no idea like i
went on the megan kelly show a month ago
i sounded like an idiot she's asking me
these questions about like
atlanta voting laws and i'm telling
jokes about my dad
and i'm just like [ __ ] i sound like a
dumb [ __ ] yeah so
you know but you live and you learn so
with comedians all with this victim
stuff is like
oh you know you say you don't have a
show anymore
just shut up just make the new thing
you're a comedian just make it you know
you take these things away from me
i'll try to keep fighting to make the
new thing then yeah like i'll just keep
continuing to do that and then if i lose
on it all
i'll go back to physical therapy and
then if you i'll just continue to keep
trying i'm never going to blame anybody
for my misfortunes it's always rests on
me it's like the communities that blame
the audience it's like
dude i know some audiences are better
than us but it's your job to it's our
job to figure it out
yeah every night you just have to figure
it out and sometimes you do sometimes
you don't but it's like
yeah maybe the audi yeah it's not the
audience's fault they were harder that
night sure but you stood out you had to
[ __ ] dig deeper
and there's plenty of times where you
know i don't i bomb all the time were
you really a pt
yeah i still am i go the great governor
cuomo
from new york just um
just uh in the beginning of the pandemic
he reinstated every health
professional's license that had lapsed
because of the pandemic or whatever
because we were you know physical
therapists would
became important for like respiratory
therapy so my license had lapsed because
i stopped doing physical therapy in 2013
and then i think
it lapsed in like 2018 i never
reinstated because i've been you know
just doing this full time
but then i got a letter in the mail that
was like hey you're licensed you can go
treat physical now i've my license is
good so i think 2024.
so i'm like technically still a lot but
do you know the move still
i was a pediatric physical therapist
mostly so i could work on you because
you have little
little body parts but you know somebody
with with with bigger feet no
wait wait what like kalila i would have
to i would have one
of those beautiful big feet yes
i'm pediatric what does that mean it
means you're a baby baby because you're
because your body's smaller you look
like most of the children i treated with
down syndrome
that they're they're to work with yes
it's true all right don't let that out i
want people to know that